there were times when I would I would
just to see what it would do I would
take half a gram of mushrooms a day and
or one mushroom one gram of mushrooms a
day I hated all these states
I quickly abandon all these experiments
because all I could do with those kinds
of doses was it made me anxious it made
me think a lot about the fact that I
wasn't really high but it was rougher
than coffee and just was kind of crazy
making and so I I meant that I believe
in large doses rarely I think that's
what's effective and the people want to
tiptoe in if you're a tiptoe in ur back
to the ashram for you this is no game
for those who wish to tiptoe because
those are dangerous areas those shallow
waters most psychedelic people I think
would agree where it's it's not the high
dose that blasts your world to
smithereens that leaves people upset and
confused that's usually experienced as a
kind of liberation what leaves people
upset and confused is to get half in and
half out and not be able to come contact
the transcendent but to have all their
baggage in there with them fully
illuminated and then you know other
people complicated I find other people
very complicated other people it just
stands to reason are the most
complicated objects in your year
and you know when I'm stoned on seven or
eight grams of psilocybin for me to be
able to handle a chunk of orange without
getting excited to the point of hysteria
is so let alone having somebody maybe
want to have sex with you or maybe want
to discuss their bad trip with you or
maybe want to move from here down to the
beach or maybe one and just say you know